When hiring new employees especially the
very first few, you want an employees
that fundamentally believe in the vision
and the mission of the company.
Because that will dictate
the culture going forward, you want
the first few employees to really set
the tone for everyone that comes after.
So whatever environment, whatever
culture you're trying to instill.
Those early employees will
help you determine that.
So, if your company's such that work
life balance is very important and
you work 9 to 6 very hard and
then everybody goes home, find
employees that are aligned with that.
If your company culture is different,
find employees that aligned with
whatever vision you have for
your company because that will clearly
determine a lot on future hires and
the tone of the business and
your style of going forward.